Facebook and Instagram are moving right
now to ban permanently project Veritas
from their platforms and the reason is
the Pfizer sting video because that was
a good one right so we have to do that
if we're going to do that though there's
a risk of like as you could imagine no
one wants to be having a farmer company
mutating James O'Keefe he usually brings
the heat I mean he comes with really
good stuff not every project Veritas
expose is created equal some of them
have been less shocking than others this
one's pretty good the Pfizer exact video
is pretty good and Facebook and
Instagram know it that's why they want
to ban James O'Keefe and project Veritas
even Twitter under Elon locked project
very toss out for about two hours I
assume then they got the call from Elon
he's like what are you guys doing put
project very test back on but if Elon
did not run Twitter project fairytos
almost certainly would still be off the
platform they don't want us talking
about that and and to me this is a meta
political lesson the politics of
politics that's worth paying attention
to